où
j'ai envie de rester à new york un
moment du futur j'ai plus envie
d'analyser le travail des autres car
j'ai envie d'écrire que diriez vous de
travailler dans une agence littéraire
j'adorerais mais est ce que vous savez
tapé à la machine s'était pas la même
chose que de taper sur ces affreuses
ordinateur
[Musique]
vous avez publié de la poésie wii ne
mentionnait pas les écrivains sont les
pires assistant au travail
devinez qui ma patronne représente
adresse le pape allemand spiegel
j'ai dit ça lengert et sérieuse salinger
vous avez sûrement entendu dire qu'il
est fou ce n'est pas lui le problème ce
sont ces gens qui appellent sans relâche
pour obtenir son adresse son numéro de
téléphone vous devrez y répondre
salinger ne reçoit jamais ces lettres
n'ont jamais monsieur salinger ne
souhaite pas recevoir de courrier
joyce apprécie beaucoup je veux éviter
de perturber sa routine je n'ai pas
envie d'être une routine
qu'est ce que tu comptes faire toi c'est
ton rêve d'écrire mais là tu travailles
comme une folle pour d'autres équipes à
d'autres choses que de répondre au
téléphone johanna break
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es allé trop loin c'est une grave
erreur
[Musique]
très bien ça faisait du métier
je ne voulais pas d'une vie ordinaire
je voulais une vie extraordinaire